welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and doctor strange in the
multiverse madness bled quite a bit of
madness into the multiverse despite not
spending that much time in it spoilers
ahead with the leaders of the marvel
universe 838 wiped out faster than you
could say i'm sorry without a mouth the
scarlet witch's massacre of the
illuminati at first reads as a kind of
meta toying with fan expectations but
really the more you unpack this film the
more you realize that we actually
learned quite a bit about marvel
universe 838 and how it's really a
universe where the x-men the avengers
fantastic war in humans and more are now
gunning for the wanda maxima this movie
leaves behind so let's break down some
key facts this film established about
universe 838 this universe is shaped in
many ways by the technological advances
of reed richards and his cooperation
with the brightest minds of the
sorcerers humankind mutant kind and
humankind and a cree kind urban life is
a clean energy utopia with waterfalls
and greenhouses built into skyscrapers
this might actually be where the 616
manhattan is headed with spider-man far
from home showing avengers tower being
reconstructed with a leafy atrium and a
sign on the ground floor teasing we
cannot wait to show you what comes next
with a nod to the number four now reed
richards says in this movie that he has
a wife and children referring to
fantastic four members susan storm the
invisible woman and their children
franklin richards and valeria richards
doctor strange jokes asking if the
fantastic four charted in the 60s and
not to his wide reference face of pop
music release dates from the first film
feels so good jack mangione 1977. like
the pop seekers uh 1975 beautiful
loser's side ah and the way the mcu has
compared super groups in the past to the
beatles the avengers broke up broke up
like a band like like the beatles also
reminded us that peyton reed's pitch
took wanting to do a fantastic four
movie set in the 60s like a hard day's
night either way the way that the comic
silver age established the marvel
universe as being one built on the
foundation of the fantastic four so too
was this 838 universe but the avengers
also exist in a38 because they call
captain carter the first avenger and she
is suited up the way peggy is in what if
suggesting this is a reality similar to
that series where peggy received the
super soldier serum instead of steve
rogers but that also might mean that
skinny steve is the hydra stomper
existing in this reality along with all
the other avengers who would exist in
that world now there is a bit of
inconsistency when it comes to why they
would be called the avengers as captain
marvel 2019 showed us how carol danvers
pilot call sign of avenger was where
nick fury got the name for the avengers
initiative in this universe maria rambo
is captain marvel and her call sign was
photon so wouldn't they be called the
photons no probably not i mean we don't
know exactly what maria's alternate
origin was maybe carol avengers danvers
had some other important historical role
or maybe 838 nick fury could have come
up with the name avengers without it
being anyone's call sign as we all
thought before 2019 anyway but important
note the illuminati has ultron sentries
which would suggest an iron man tony
stark would also exist in this universe
as this particular appearance of ultron
which by the way was voiced by ross
marquand who voiced ultron and what if
doing his best james spader impression
that ultron was modeled on 616 tony
stark's iron legion drones but then
again in the comics it was hank pym who
invented ultron either way this tech
very well could have been invented by
reed now i pointed out a seventh empty
chair on that deus that i keep bringing
up and everyone keeps tweeting me saying
oh was it just 838 steven's chair no
folks it was not because 838 steven
strange was sorcerer supreme and when
the sorcerer's supreme died they gave
the sorcerer's supreme seat to mordo
mordo was not a member of the illuminati
when they were all on titan they clearly
have one chair for each faction head
sorcerer supreme chair a mutant kind
leader chair an avengers leader chair a
defender of the cosmos leader chair etc
etc there is no reason they would leave
that empty chair there while they had a
lot of respect for sorcerer supreme
strange they made it clear that they
felt pretty betrayed by him they already
kept that shrine on the outside of the
sanctum there's no reason they would
keep that chair empty now for a guy who
almost destroyed their universe so there
must be some seventh illuminati member
that we have not seen it could be
superior iron man tony stark it could be
hank pym or it could be t'challa who in
the comics they originally reached out
to to join this team but he said no now
obviously x-men exist in 838 it's not
exactly the charles xavier we saw in all
of the fox x-men movies he seems more
modeled on the animated version but he
does call back an important line from
x-men days to future past just because
someone stumbles loses their way it
doesn't mean they're lost
and remember that movie ended by
restoring a present timeline with
charles in his first hover chair so
rather than that leading to the tragic
future of the film logan like some of us
thought that movie's director james
bengal never confirmed that to be the
case anyway instead that days of future
past ending might have been this 838
universe a universe with hugh jackman
wolverine james marsden cyclops famkee
janssen jean grey halle berry storm and
the rest and the charles xavier that
wanda left these heroes to bury actually
if you look closely at the moment wanda
snaps charles's neck inside the mind
realm one hand on the top of his face
pulls one way one hand on the bottom of
his face pulls another folks she did not
just snap his neck in that realm she
literally ripped his mental face in half
now it can be hard to see the light at
the end of the tunnel when you have high
interest debt and sometimes it can even
feel harder to ask for help well that's
where upstart comes in upstart powered
personal loans can help you pay off high
interest debt all online with simple and
easy to understand payment terms upstart
has helped over 1.8 million customers on
their path to financial freedom whether
it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses upstart can
help you get one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff date upstart knows
that you are more than just your credit
score so rather than looking at your
credit score alone upstart's model
considers other factors like your income
your employment and other information
provided in your loan application to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
you can check your rate in minutes for
loans between 1000 to 50 000 without
impacting your credit score you can even
receive funds as fast as one business
day after accepting your loan so don't
wait and check your rate today at
upstart.com new rockstars that's
upstart.com new rockstars to check your
rate today don't forget to use our url
to let them know that we sent you go to
upstart.com new rockstars and something
that goes overlooked for multiverse of
madness is that 838 is also the universe
of that variant whom 616 scarlet witch
possessed and the same wanda variant who
forgave her in the film's climax
therefore 838 is a universe where wanda
had reached her ideal family life with
vision how did she do that well
charles's vision of their battle with
thanos on titan showed thanos infinity
gauntlet with only four of the six
infinity stones power stone space stone
reality stone soul stone no time stone
and no mind stone that means that the
vision of this universe never had the
mind stone ripped out of his head and he
might still be alive if vision ever
existed in 838 and presumably he does
because ultron centuries exist those
sentries bear the final form that ultron
created after he tried to create a
replacement synthesized body that the
avengers would turn into vision now
ultron centuries being subservient
doesn't mean tony stark's ultron program
worked from the get-go and prevented
vision's existence completely because
ultron was really just an algorithm ai
meant for tony's iron legions tony never
built ultron centuries that looked like
this ultron replicated himself and
ultron only went to activate functional
sentries late in the events of age of
ultron after vision was already underway
so these ultrons must come from reality
where the avengers were able to regain
control of the centuries after a battle
of sokovia crisis happened honestly
probably thanks to vision and wanda so
therefore if we assume that vision
exists in this universe since thanos
never got the mind stone vision would
still be alive and after the illuminati
defeated thanos wanda envisioned could
just build that life on that new jersey
plot of land that vision bought for
wanda as we saw in juan division episode
8 wanda's west view hex reality could
have simply been a true tangible reality
in a38 where was vision in this movie
left off the coal sheet because they
couldn't afford paul bettany i bet but
either way remember when a38 wanda was
possessed by 616 scarlet witch 838 wanda
was buried inside of the scarlet witch's
subconscious stuck under trapped rubble
with a tv set showing the intro to one
division episode one now we don't know
if the rebel imagery came from the 616
soul or the 838 soul but if it was the
latter it would mean that 838 wanda also
had an origin in sokovia when that stark
warhead destroyed her home when dick van
dyke was on a similar tv set it's just
been another clue that tony stark also
exists in this universe so 838 wanda
ends his film seemingly alive and well
with her sons promising 616 scarlet
witch that they will be loved but
remember from her point of view this
woman was possessed by a version of
herself from another reality her body
was used to murder 838's top leaders
this would make this 838 wanda the most
feared individual in that reality a
nexus b that everyone left in 838 which
includes mordo susan storm and the other
fantastic four the other avengers
including steve rogers and possibly tony
stark and possibly black panther the
other x-men including wolverine and jean
grey all the inhumans who are left over
the cree the squirrels all of them might
now see 838 wanda as a volatile wanda of
mass destruction capable of being
overtaken by an evil variant another
time in the future i know you're gonna
say that every darkhold was destroyed
but strange's third eye remains in his
head implying that the curse of the
darkhold and the incursions it causes
remain possible across this universe and
you cannot tell me that the loved ones
of these illuminati would walk through
the halls of that baxter foundation
seeing their corpses and not want to
hold someone responsible this
wandophobia is exactly what led to the
house of m event in the comics in which
the top brass of the marvel world meet
to decide how to solve this problem of
wanda wanda responds by warping reality
to a mutant-dominated house of m
universe wolverine fights back restoring
everyone's memories and then wanda just
declares no more mutants and somewhere
bummed a version of this house of m
storyline didn't happen to multiverse
madness but i'm here to tell you now the
table is fully set for house of m to
happen in the live action 838 universe
we got x-men and the avengers in the
fantastic four united in their fear of
awanda maximoff a poor woman who wants
nothing more than to just live with her
family is 838 christine palmer gonna
stand in the way of all those pissed off
superheroes is anyone gonna care that it
wasn't 838 wanda's doing but just one of
her variants controlling her mind and
assuming vision is alive right now is he
gonna stand a chance by her side against
all these people it's gonna be an
interesting match-up and time will tell
but as of now wanda maximoff does not
die at the end of doctor strange's
multiverse of madness my friends she is
more alive than ever and too many people
this reality more of a threat than ever
she lives in a universe filled with more
marvel superheroes than we've ever seen
and every last one of them has wanda in
their crosshairs hey follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos following
the rockstar subscribe to the rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you